Speaker 1: All right.
Speaking of twenty, twenty four, in addition
to speaking at CPAC, Donald Trump gave an
absolutely absurd interview to Fox News's
Maria Bartiromo.
She will not question anything.
Trump says he can get away with anything he
could say.
Maria, you're now you do whatever he she will
not question anything that Donald Trump says.
And during this interview, Trump seems to
say he's running in twenty, twenty four.
We'll get to that.
And also effectively claimed that the death
of a January 6th Trump writer named Ashley
Babbette was essentially a political assassination
by a Democratic staffer.
This is truly dangerous stuff.
Let's get into it.
Speaker 4: Well, that's right.
And I want to talk about that because Ashley
Babbette, a wonderful woman, fatally shot
on January 6th as she tried to climb out.
Now notice,
Speaker 1: normally when people are killed
by police, people like Maria and Trump defend
the police.
They say, don't break the law, then you won't
get shot, this woman, this wonderful woman,
the sheep, she was there illegally, she was
trespassing.
And if the situation was reversed, they'd
be saying, why was she even there
Speaker 4: of a broken window?
Her family has spoken out.
Her family has been on Tucker Carlson.
And they want answers as far as why this wonderful
woman, young woman who went to peaceful protest
was shot.
Speaker 1: Is anything true?
She was she was there criminally and it was
not a peaceful protest.
It's terrible that she died.
It's absolutely terrible.
But this is revisionist history.
Speaker 4: Guys have any information.
There is speculation that this was a security
detail in a leading member of Congress, his
security detail, a Democrat.
What can you tell us in terms of who shot?
Actually, what do you know, Mr. President?
Speaker 7: So I've heard that I will tell
you, they know who shot Ashley Babbitt.
They're protecting that person.
I've heard also that it was the head of security
for a certain high official, a Democrat.
And we'll see.
Speaker 1: Because conspiracies, conspiracies
about what took place and where is the support
of the police.
Normally, they're all about support the police.
And then Maria Bartiromo strongly suggests
that it was a Chuck Schumer staffer who shot
and killed Ashley Babbitt.
I have no idea.
Could that possibly be true?
I don't know.
But the speculation is very irresponsible.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's actually quite extraordinary,
I want you to know that my team reached out
to Senator Chuck Schumer's office to check
on what he may know about who shot Ashley
Babbette.
We have not heard back from Chuck Schumer's
office.
We did send a note and call.
What do you think?
Do you know what,
Speaker 7: President, I wonder what you know,
they they talk big and they're real law and
order people when it comes to a certain group,
but with another group, they can do whatever
they want.
Speaker 1: One of the most irresponsible interviews
I could imagine, and this continues here,
is more of this innocent, beautiful, wonderful
woman stuff.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that report showed FBI operatives
potentially aware, but there are unanswered
questions here.
What did the FBI know?
Why weren't your cabinet secretaries briefed?
What did Speaker Pelosi know?
Chuck Schumer and McConnell?
Do you have any answers to that?
They continue to.
Speaker 1: How much of a look at the gaslighting.
Trump instigated the riots and she's interviewing
Trump.
But it's all about what was Pelosi's role?
What was Chuck Schumer's what are you talking
Speaker 4: about all this time around?
And yet no guns were seized, Mr. President.
Speaker 7: Right.
There were no guns whatsoever.
And yet and TSA, which went into Portland
and went into so many other places, Seattle,
they took over a big part of Seattle.
People died.
And there were plenty of guns there, by the
way.
And in Minnesota and Minneapolis
Speaker 1: now, in fact, there were stun guns
seized, baseball bats, flagpoles being wielded
as clubs, even against police.
Pipe bombs were planted pepper spray and on
and on and on.
Here is more of Trump rewriting history on
the January 6th riots.
I mean, look at look at what is taking place
in this country.
Speaker 4: Mr. President, you just referred
to the twenty twenty election, I want to refer
you to an article in the Federalist over the
weekend, and it says New evidence indicates
enough illegal votes in Georgia to tip the
20 20 results.
This is from the Federalist.
I want to get your thoughts on what's taking
place right now in Arizona and in Georgia
with regard to that.
Speaker 1: What's going on is nothing, but
they're calling them audits.
Speaker 4: Continue to post and discuss election
twenty, twenty one.
Speaker 7: Well, the Federalist, they have
35000 votes, and that's far more numerous
times more than no.
We need to win that state.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So Trump continuing with that stuff and then
going directly from rewriting the election
to rewriting what happened on January 6th.
Then remember, Maria, has the guy who instigated
it here won't ask about that?
Speaker 4: President, let me move on.
The fencing around the Capitol is beginning
to come down this week and this weekend.
And I know that you have had some time to
reflect on what took place on that day, January
6th.
Talk to us about what you're thinking about
as you reflect what happened that day from
your standpoint.
Speaker 7: So there was a big rally called.
And actually, when I say big, who knew?
But there was a rally called and a tremendous
number of people, the largest one I've ever
spoken before, is called by people, by patriots.
Speaker 1: Notice every rally he's spoken
at is like the one that's been most attended
in history, every rally.
Speaker 7: And they asked to be invited to
speak.
And I did.
And it was a very mild mannered speech that
I think has been in fact, they just came out
with a report in Congress and they did mention
my name.
Speaker 1: That's untrue.
That report mentions him dozens of times,
surely.
Speaker 7: But what they were complaining
about and the reason, in my opinion, you had
over a million people there, which the press
doesn't like to report at all because it shows
there
Speaker 1: were not a million people
Speaker 7: there.
Too much too much activity, too much, too
much spirit and faith and love.
There was such much love at that rally.
You had over a million people that they were
Speaker 1: you didn't have a million people
there
Speaker 7: for one reason, the rigged election,
they felt the election was rigged.
That's why they were there and they were peaceful
people.
These were great.
Speaker 1: So Trump completely gaslighting,
saying his speech was totally mild.
Well, you told them to go and they did exactly
what you said.
He says they were there for a legitimate reason,
which is the election was stolen, which it
wasn't.
And he says that they were peaceful.
There were hundreds of people known to be
committing crimes and some unknown that are
still being looked at.
OK, real quick to last things.
And one of them is Trump on twenty twenty
four.
Here is Trump lamenting that the Supreme Court
didn't steal the election for him.
Speaker 7: So this was a terrible blot on
our country and our country's history and
our country as a, you know, free and fair
place.
This you can't allow this to happen.
We were very disappointed by the Supreme Court
because they didn't have the courage to take
it up, that
Speaker 1: they couldn't give you the presidency.
And he's mad at Pence.
He's mad at Barr, he's mad at the Supreme
Court.
He simply lost and he can't accept that.
Now, here's the last thing.
Trump on twenty twenty four.
I think he's saying he's running.
Guys, from what I'm hearing here,
Speaker 7: Republicans against any Democrat,
they want to do anything they can to stop
that.
These are dirty players and it shouldn't happen.
It's a disgrace.
Speaker 4: All right, so the question is,
will you make the run again, you said that
you know your answer, but you're not revealing
it yet.
You ready to get back in that ring and run
for president again?
Speaker 7: Sir, sir, I do know my answer,
but I can't reveal it yet.
And because that has to do with campaign financing
and everything, so I can't reveal it yet.
But I absolutely know my answer.
And we're going to do very well and people
are going to be very happy.
And, you know, I look at cable ratings, I
look at the ratings of CNN down.
All right.
Speaker 1: So he says we're going to do very
well and people are going to be very happy.
I think he's saying that he's running now.
He may be lying.
He may just be saying it to continue the grifting,
to continue raising money.
But Trump seems to be saying he is running
in twenty twenty for another bizarre, unhinged
interview and hugely irresponsible